Os voy a hacer una pregunta y no vale buscarlo
en Google…
¿Cuál es el país que tiene más mujeres
en el parlamento?
Muchos estaréis pensando en Noruega, Suecia
o tal vez Gran Bretaña…
¡Pues nada de eso!
La respuesta es RUANDA, uno de los lugares
más pobres del África subsahariana.
Estoy seguro de que muchos ya conocéis este
país.
Al menos, los que tengáis cierta edad.
En el año 1994, el genocidio ruandés salía
en los informativos de todos los periódicos.
Hablamos de uno de las mayores atrocidades
de la historia de la humanidad.
En sólo 100 días, el Gobierno ruandés masacró
a casi 1 millón de personas de la forma más
salvaje que os podáis imaginar.
Para que os hagáis una idea, eso significa
que 1 de cada 5 ruandeses fue asesinado.
Durante décadas, Ruanda fue un sinónimo
de catástrofe humanitaria, de hambrunas sistemáticas
y un recordatorio de lo más oscuro de la
condición humana.
Sin embargo, hoy en día, en el año 2017,
23 años más tarde, Ruanda se está convirtiendo
en algo muy distinto:
“Reflexiones de Ruanda; invirtiendo en una
de las economías de más rápido crecimiento
del mundo”
Tal cual como lo oís.
Ruanda se está poniendo de moda en el mundo
financiero.
Un país que antes sólo aparecía en los
anuncios de ayuda humanitaria, ahora empieza
a salir en la prensa económica.
Su presidente, el eterno Paul Kagame, se ha
convertido en la nueva rock star africana.
Se pasea por escenarios tan prestigiosos como
Harvard o el Instituto Brookings.
Sí, vale, todos reconocen que su estilo de
gobierno es un tanto autoritario.
Que eso de llevar 17 años en el poder y decir
que ganas elecciones con el 96% del voto es
de todo menos democrático.
Pero ¿Quién se atreve a reprocharle algo
al hombre que está sacando Ruanda de la pobreza?
Las cifras hablan por sí solas.
Desde que Paul Kagame está en el gobierno,
los ruandeses casi han triplicado sus ingresos
y la población que vive en la pobreza extrema
se está reduciendo año tras año.
Así que la pregunta es…
¿Cómo ha llegado Ruanda hasta aquí?
Y lo que es más importante ¿Realmente es
tan impresionante el éxito económico de
este país…
o hay letra pequeña?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas.
Y vamos a contaros una historia que, al menos
a mí, me ha hecho cuestionarme muchos de
mis principios.
Preparaos porque el vídeo de hoy va a ser,
cuanto menos, intenso…
ODIO PREFABRICADO
Recordad esta fecha: 6 de abril de 1994.
El avión en el que volaba el presidente de
Ruanda fue derribado por un cañón antiaéreo.
Nadie sabe, a ciencia cierta, quién organizó
ese ataque.
Pero el ejército ruandés, compuesto por
miembros de la tribu de los HUTU, culpó de
este magnicidio a la tribu rival: los TUTSIS.
Los tutsis era una minoría dentro de Ruanda
que vivían en una situación de apartheid.
Los medios locales se referían a ellos como
“cucarachas” y muchos de ellos habían
escapado a campos de refugiados en los países
vecinos.
Pero nadie podía esperar que este magnicidio
fuera a desatar semejante carnicería.
“Aviso para todas las cucarachas que están
escuchándonos…
Ruanda pertenece a aquellos que realmente
la defienden.
Los tutsis no llegan al 8% de la población.
Si les exterminamos, nadie nos juzgará porque
habremos ganado”
Mientras estos mensajes se difundían por
la radio, el ejército ruandés estaba repartiendo
machetes y garrotes entre la población civil.
Si alguno de estos hutus mostraba algún signo
de clemencia con sus vecinos tutsis, se arriesgaba
a ser ejecutado por colaboracionismo.
Eso explica que muchos ruandeses ejecutaran
a sus mujeres tutsis a garrotazos o que incluso
algunas iglesias católicas se convirtieran
en auténticos mataderos humanos.
En tan sólo 100 días, casi 1 millón de
personas murieron a machetazos por sus propios
vecinos.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué los hutus odiaban
tanto a los tutsis?
¿Acaso eran tan diferentes?
Pues lo cierto es que no.
Veréis, hay muchos países Africanos con
varias razas y culturas conviviendo.
En Sudáfrica, por ejemplo, hay 9 idiomas
oficiales.
En Uganda, la cifra supera los 15.
Sin embargo, Ruanda fue un territorio sorprendentemente
homogéneo durante siglos.
Una única lengua y una única cultura.
Tanto los hutus, como los tutsis como las
demás tribus convivían en relativa armonía…
hasta que, en el siglo XX llegaron los colonizadores
BELGAS.
Una de las primeras medidas que puso el gobierno
de Bélgica en Ruanda fue obligar a todos
los locales a identificar claramente la tribu
a la que pertenecían.
De esta forma, era fácil reconocerles a simple
vista.
Durante los primeros años, los TUTSIS controlaban
las instituciones de gobierno de los belgas.
Pero en el momento en el que reclamaron más
independencia, Bélgica empezó a apoyar a
los HUTUS.
Todo esto acompañado de toda clase de propaganda
racista.
De esta forma, cuando en 1962, Ruanda se independiza
de Bélgica, los hutus y los tutsis ya tenían
sus primeros enfrentamientos.
Muchos tutsis estaban empezando a campos de
refugiados.
Entre ellos, este señor que véis aquí,
que se llama PAUL KAGAME.
Quedaros con este nombre, porque es muy importante.
Paul Kagame se crió en uno de esos campos
de refugiados en Uganda, donde vivían todos
los tutsis que habían escapado de Ruanda.
Era el principio de los años 80.
Por aquel entonces, Uganda estaba en mitad
de una guerra civil.
Kagame, junto con otros refugiados ruandeses,
luchó contra el gobierno ugandés… y ganó.
Así es como se comenzó a forjar su prestigio
como estratega militar.
Después, en los años 90, Kagame lideraría
varias incursiones militares contra el gobierno
ruandés.
Pero el momento clave llegó en 1994.
100 días después de ese fatídico 6 de abril,
Paul Kagame entraba en Kigali, la capital
de Ruanda, con 2500 soldados.
El genocidio había terminado.
Y Ruanda tenía un nuevo gobierno.
Un gobierno de mayoría tutsi donde Kagame
era el vicepresidente.
Pero esperad un momento porque la historia
no termina aquí.
Imaginaos el escenario.
Por un lado, teníamos un país completamente
dividido, donde los supervivientes del genocidio
tenían que convivir con los vecinos que habían
masacrado a sus familiares.
Por el otro, Ruanda era uno de los 10 países
más pobres del planeta y a duras penas tenía
recursos naturales que poder exportar.
Y, como guinda del pastel, este nuevo gobierno
tutsi tampoco era ningún ejemplo de transparencia
y respeto por los derechos humanos.
Muchos de esos soldados que habían tomado
Kigali querían venganza… y durante los
años siguientes, nadie
hizo nada por evitar ejecuciones sumarias
y juicios con nulas garantías.
Por si esto fuera poco, muchos ministros intentaban
aprovecharse de su cargo para llenarse los
bolsillos con el poco dinero que había disponible.
Mientras tanto, nuestro amigo Paul Kagame
contaba con el apoyo popular, el carisma y,
sobretodo, la ambición política.
Por eso, en el año 2000, el gobierno dimitió
y, sin siquiera convocar elecciones, terminó
ocurriendo lo inevitable…
KAGAME, EL PRESIDENTE ETERNO
En el año 2000, Paul Kagame se convierte
en el presidente de Ruanda.
Y llega al poder con dos objetivos muy claros.
El primero, cerrar las heridas que había
dejado el genocidio.
El segundo, sacar a su país de la pobreza
¿Y qué hizo para conseguirlo?
Pues viajar.
Tal cual como lo oís.
Kagame preparó un equipo de personas de confianza
y se marcharon a países como China, Tailandia
o Singapur ¿Sabéis lo que tienen en común
estos tres sitios?
¡Exacto!
Son tres países que, en su día, fueron muy
pobres pero que por aquel entonces, ya formaban
parte de eso que llamamos los “países emergentes”.
Kagame se reunió con políticos, economistas
y funcionarios, apuntó ideas en una libreta
y volvió a su país con la receta para construir
un país rico.
Esa libreta fue la base tanto de la Constitución
ruandesa como del famoso proyecto Visión
Ruanda 2020.
Básicamente, Paul Kagame se planteó que
su país debería convertirse en una economía
de renta media en sólo 2 décadas.
Un país pacífico, moderno y donde al menos
la pobreza extrema haya desaparecido.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esto no se
trata del típico discurso vacío de político!
El programa Ruanda 2020 consta de 44 objetivos
claros y medibles.
Cosas como que para el año 2020, 1 de cada
3 ruandeses tiene que tener electricidad en
casa.
Tanto el gobierno como distintas consultoras
privadas se dedican a analizar hasta qué
punto se está avanzando en estos objetivos.
Y por ejemplo, uno de los objetivos que ya
han conseguido cumplir es el de la igualdad
de género.
La Constitución ruandesa exige que, al menos
el 50% de todos los cargos políticos estén
ocupados por mujeres.
Y de hecho, en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo, en el año 2017, el parlamento
de Ruanda es el que más proporción de mujeres
tiene en el mundo entero.
La brecha salarial entre hombres y mujeres
es más baja, incluso, que en países tan
progresistas como Dinamarca y hay toda una
generación de mujeres empresarias levantando
el país.
Por otra parte, el Ruanda ha sabido invertir
el poco dinero que recauda.
En un país donde el 80% de la población
vivía de la agricultura de subsistencia,
el gobierno ha construido plantas de generación
de energía y carreteras que han conseguido
mejorar la productividad del campo.
Hoy en día, los agricultores ruandeses están
empezando a exportar a sus países vecinos.
Todo esto explica que, 23 años después del
genocidio, Ruanda está creciendo a una media
del 8% año tras año.
Esto es un ritmo similar al de otras economías
emergentes como China o Vietnam.
En las mismas calles donde en 1994, los vecinos
se mataban a machetazos, ahora surgen empresas
como la RWANDA MOTORCICLES COMPANY, que es
una fábrica de motos que se ha creado este
mismo año 2017 con capital estadounidense.
Para que hagáis una idea, mientras en el
resto de países de la región necesitas semanas
o incluso meses para crear una empresa, en
Ruanda sólo hacen falta dos días para hacer
todos los papeles.
Y eso ha atraído a toda clase de inversores
internacionales, sobretodo de China y Estados
Unidos.
Pero os preguntaréis ¿Cómo han llegado
hasta aquí?
¿Cuál es el secreto de Paul Kagame?
Pues, mis queridos
amigos de VisualPolitik, la respuesta tiene
sus luces y sus sombras.
TOLERANCIA A PUNTA DE PISTOLA
Todo el mundo lo reconoce: Ruanda es un país
que funciona.
Las calles son seguras y la tolerancia entre
hutus y tutsis está impuesta por ley.
La propia constitución ruandesas prohíbe
utilizar estos términos para referirse a
una persona.
Todos son ruandeses, sin importar la tribu
de donde vengan.
Y ni las instituciones ni los medios de comunicación
pueden lanzar ningún mensaje que pueda incitar,
ni siquiera ligeramente, a abrir las heridas
del pasado.
Es más, ni siquiera pueden criticar al gobierno.
Y tanto la policía como el ejército están
presentes en todo el país para garantizar
que así sea.
Sí, es cierto, Paul Kagame es un presidente
cercano al pueblo, conocido por tener su canal
de youtube, un twitter y un Facebook que utiliza
casi a diario.
Pero nadie más tiene libertad para expresar
sus ideas libremente.
Lo mismo ocurre con el resto de partidos políticos.
Hablamos de un presidente que lleva ya 17
años en el poder y que gana elecciones con
resultados que superan el 95%.
Como os podéis imaginar, eso tiene poco de
democrático.
“Uno de sus opositores, Frank Habineza,
del único partido de oposición, ha intentado
presentarse a las elecciones del año 2010
pero su partido no pudo registrarse para las
votaciones”
En otras palabras, el modelo ruandés se fundamenta
en tres pilares: facilidad para hacer invertir
dinero desde el extranjero y hacer negocios,
construcción de infraestructuras y, por encima
de todo, un gobierno autoritario que garantiza
la seguridad y la tolerancia…
a base de reprimir el resto de derechos.
Y aquí es donde llega la pregunta final…
¿Os parece legítima esta falta de democracia
y de libertades si a cambio un país puede
salir de la miseria más absoluta?
¿O tal vez Ruanda debería abrirse a un modelo
democrático como el que tenemos en Europa
o buena parte de Latinoamérica?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Si queréis conocer a fondo otro país africano,
en este vídeo os cuento la historia de Angola,
el país más caro del mundo.
Y como siempre, recordad que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto!